welcome ladies and gentlemen to our
second Talk of the day here from Vision
to action designing and deploying
effective computer vision pipelines I'm
joined here today by um Yun uh oh no by
wesy B sorry Yun can join us today uh
wesy bik is's a lead machine learning uh
engineer at accelerated uh working on
very cool projects uh heill guide is
building robust computer vision pipes
sign using open source tools sharing
real insights from Real World
applications like predictive maintenance
in the port of rdam a very cool project
if you ask me so whether you're an
expert or newcomer this session promises
practical knowledge to design deploy and
maintain impactful computer vision
systems so have a warm welcome for
Wesley all
[Applause]
[Music]
right thank you good morning welcome to
my talk from Vision to action and let's
start today with a few questions first
question who has used or trained a
computer fion model
once okay quite a bit of hands let's go
to a second question who has ever
deployed a computer vision
model yeah few more hands and then the
last question who has ever maintains a
computer vision model in
production okay few of you nice to see
that my goal for today is to bring you
from question one more to question three
and get you some insights on how to do
that so what's going to be the topic for
today um it's going to be computer
vision and it's going to be mlops but
not the two topics in isolation because
there's already a lot of information out
there today I want to talk about the
intersection of this how the mlops
practices changes when we're talking
about a computer vision project what the
interesting things are that we can learn
from what the insights are so who Am I
who are we my name is Wesley I was
supposed to be here with my my colleague
Yun however his wife gave birth
yesterday to their newborn kid so that's
a perfect reason not to be here we
already anticipated on this right there
was a due date so I'm fully prepared to
deliver this on my own um but I did this
project together with
Yun um so I'm Wesley I'm the elite ml
engineer at accelerated Yun is also an
ml engineer at kep Gemini different
companies so how is how is it that we
happen to do a presentation here
together and that's because we work
together on the project for Port of rdam
um which which project what was it it's
a computer vision project it was for the
asset management uh Department of Port
of rdam they are responsible for the
road and Waterway infrastructure to keep
it all on a high quality to make sure
there's no safety incidents to make sure
that the port is in the best shape as it
can be um to do so they have to maintain
an area of over 100 square kilometers
and make sure all infrastructure is um
good there and they do a lot of
inspections there but there's a few
drawbacks on doing these inspections by
human it is time intensive it makes it
expensive because it requires experts
driving up and down the harbor all the
time and it's sometimes unsafe they use
these vehicles um to do their
inspections they cannot do it while
driving so they have to stop on places
where you're not supposed to park you
have to get out of the car you have to
do some kind of measurements all for
like there's a lot of trucks driving
through the harbor so that's something
that's not ideal to give an idea of the
shape of the area that they are
inspecting this is um the road from the
world port center the headquarters of
Port of rdam all the way to the second M
Mass fluxor like the newest building
build part of the harbor and it takes
about 50 minutes drive over the highway
to get there so when they're Ted to do
an inspection all the way over there it
already takes them 1 hour to get there
and one hour to get back and we thought
okay we can we can do this smarter we
can actually um use video and use
computer vision to automate some of
these
inspections that's how the idea of the
machine learning inspector was born here
you see the same car the same yellow
Hoot with a camera setup on top and you
see that we take videos and we detect
and classify assets that you see on the
screen to to assess whether they are
damaged or not to assess whether there
is something that needs to happen to
make a corrective action on one of the
Assets in the
harbor and today I'm going to tell you
how we built this project uh what we
learned from it and also share some
lessons that you can also enjoy the the
mistakes and the the lessons learned
from
that um so let's talk about some of the
use cases things that we see in the
harbor are damaged traffic signs these
things don't last forever here's an
example of how they look when they're
damaged uh another one is scoot lamp
poost this is a safety issue here we see
one that is like tilted backwards but
they can also be tilted forwards and if
you have a large truck and you drive
past it you can hit it with all um
consequences from that so I take these
two examples as use cases that we've
worked on throughout the last one and a
half years um and take you on a journey
how we build this
project um let's actually start at the
end how how should this project look
like for the end user in the end is the
asset managers responsible for
maintaining these assets and their ideal
wish is to get like a map and get an
overview of what the quality is of all
their assets that they're managing
here's an example of um the map of of
rdam the harbor um with dots all over
where where we did inspections I can
zoom on a bit more on the specific
Harbor here we see all dots where we did
um inspections and the idea is that if
you click on one of them that you can
see like what the um specific inspection
was you can see like a picture and you
can see if there was damage and you can
change the status if there was like a
mistake in the damage classification if
there needs to be action it can be taken
right from this
system so this is what we want to build
and now I'm slowly going to build up how
we got to this result so from the use
cases that I just explained
to how we designed this
system and we're going to build a
pipeline this talk is called computer
vision pipelines so we're going to build
a pipeline together and we started a
start we have a car with a camera setup
and later also a ship with a camera
setup and from that we get a stream of
video and a stream of GPS points to know
the location of that specific
vehicle those go into a building block
that we call video ingestion and
anonymization and out of it comes
individual ual frames with their GPS
tacks for each uh frame we build all the
steps of the pipeline as microservices
so they are like individually contained
and they have an interface what goes in
what goes out also important to say is
we put the anonymizer right here at the
beginning because we're taking videos in
a public space and we're not allowed to
systematically register um information
about people so no license plates no
people no faces all these things getss
blurred out um from the moment that we
um start processing
them then the second step is actually
detecting the assets that we see on the
frame and we use a segmentation model
for it you actually have the choice
between like object detection or
segmentation we chose to go the route
for segmentation because it gives us the
masks the polygons to actually fully
know which pixel belongs to which asset
and you see that we have like the model
uh encapsulated in this system because
we want want to swap them out and we
want to retrain this model um and
replace it for a better model once we
get a chance we use open source modeling
open source tooling um and right now
we're using the YOLO V8 model which is
the first YOLO model that actually does
segmentation and not just object
detection so after this building block
we um get detections which are bounding
boxes plus these segmentation masks and
they go to the next step The Next Step
is object tracking and localization in a
bit I will explain more in detail how it
works um but for now we need to
understand that when we take a video we
have a lot of sequential frames where we
see the same asset like the same
physical traffic sign is what we see in
the harbor um but if we analyze each
individual frame in isolation then we
get a lot of duplicate results so we
want to trace back the objects that we
see over multiple frames you want to
combine that to give it one ID for an
asset that's what we called a trct
object and then what we also do from the
bounding box and the segmentation mask
we're able to make like a crop from this
asset to not have like the full picture
but just the asset that we're interested
in and that's going to be the output of
this third step of the
pipeline then we arrive at the point
where we have like asset specific models
and here we can make a model for skus
for example so what goes in is um the
picture and the mask of a lamp post and
what goes out is the decision whether
this asset is damaged or not whether
it's skus or whether it's a traffic sign
that gets damaged or whether it's any
other use case we kind of built this
modular pipeline where we're able to add
new use cases into this whole system um
quite quite easily and then lastly when
we have this we can publish it to the
dashboard make it available to the end
user to the stakeholder and from there
they can continue to do their job
without requiring them to sit in the
vehicle um drive through the harbor and
jump out of the car to do
inspections all right um now I want to
dive a little bit deeper into some of
the components to show like what they do
how they work uh and after that we
proceed to like what the most
interesting lessons are that we learned
from uh from this project so object
tracking like I said before one physical
asset actually has a lot of uh captures
on the video here we see two examples
one traffic sign with 28 observations
and one with 46 and after we applied our
tracking model we see that we get a nice
centered crop on each frame for this
asset and this is input for the SS
specific model like the damage
classifier um that we see how this works
is visualized here we actually use a
method of uh centroid tracking combined
with some embeddings to get uh like
similarity between embeddings on these
crops to make sure that we can do this
that was pretty tricky because most
object tracking systems are designed for
a stationary camera where something is
moving on the other side but here it's
the opposite way here we are moving from
the car and the objects are stationary
and therefore most methods that are
already out there didn't work right from
the
get-go
um then another step that I want to
highlight is the scess I want to show
you how we calculated like how scoot
such a lampost is um and we basically
take this as input we have a video here
where you see a number of lamp poost and
then like somewhere near the end we see
a lampost which is like scooted back a
little bit and with just these
segmentation masks we're able to
calculate the angle at which this one is
sced because that's the exact
information that the um inspectors and
the asset managers want to have um how
do we do this first we take the original
frame then we take the segmentation mask
and it's important that we cut off the
head of the lamp to just have like a
sort of straight um view of this uh
segmentation mask
third step that we do is rotate this
90° and then we actually take a linear
regression through this mask every white
pixel is like a hot pixel as we call it
every black one is a zero and we
basically just draw linear regression
through this mask to get the slope of
the angle that we see here um and from
that we can actually calculate the angle
compared to to the Horizon um that we
have um in this case it's an angle of 6°
and this is also the threshold for Port
of ram to replace a lamp post so when
it's over 60 Dees then it's a hazard
potential Hazard um and it has to be
replaced or at least
maintained um one last step is this is
scus compared to the Horizon but maybe
this Horizon is not straight maybe the
car is tilted a little bit maybe you
drive through corners maybe the camera
is not mounted perfectly
horizontal so what we do is we actually
calculate um the median skewness of all
lamp post that we see in the same video
and then we calculate the relative
skewness compared to the median
basically to offset if there's like
something weird with a setup um to yeah
basically to get more consistent
results then the third and last
component that I want to highlight today
is the model for uh traffic science here
we chose to make a classification model
um based on a reset 50 that we take from
torch vision and then we apply transfer
learning to a lot of like cropped images
of damaged and also like good quality
traffic signs that we have to basically
do this binary
classification um say okay these ones
are in good condition these one are in
bad condition like these are damaged to
separate them from each other this is a
bit of a simplified view because here I
only take one image and in reality we
take the whole track object so we take
all the crops and we take like um the
the mod like the most
frequent um estimation of of what the
model says and here also we only take
like damage true or false but in reality
we have multiple categories on which it
can be damaged can be like the coating
it can be like decoloration it can have
dents and holes in them it can have
gravity on them
um so there's a bit more to it but in
essence this is what we're doing and to
show you like what makes a bad quality
uh I have some examples so here we see
some traffic signs that have quite an
ugly coting uh I would say but they're
still functionally okay uh here we see
ones that are like almost unreadable so
these need to be replaced as soon as
possible and then the hardest problem is
the one of offensive graph gra it
because we can detect gravity on signs
but it's pretty hard to detect whether
it's like offensive like what's on the
gravity we still need a human in the
loop to actually decide whether um yeah
like what type of gravity there's on
this sign um but still we're able to
detect gravity so that's a that's a good
thing
um okay um now I want to continue to the
part where we have the mlops part of the
project and the computer vision
pipelines and what like the special
cases are um that you maybe not see in
the like mlop setting without computer
vision um first thing I want to
highlight is how we actually
orchestrated this Pipeline and we did it
did this based on Argo workflows so in
the bottom we see the pipeline that we
built along the way um just to highlight
again we built every step of this
pipeline as a microsurface with a fixed
interface so we can like swap them out
but also as an installable python
package that we can unit test and build
confidence in them and the nice thing is
that since they're all Docker containers
we can run this on kubernetes and we can
use Argo to uh for the workflow
execution and basically Define how these
steps in the pipeline run sequentially
some can run in parallel uh some need a
GPU because it's either a training part
or like an inference on the video some
are pretty lightweight so they don't
require a GPU um and after all these
decks directed AC graphs are all defined
in the in yaml so you can Define them in
your uh in your git
repository
um all
right second like hard thing that we had
to overcome was how we manage our
annotations we have training data in a
typical fashion you have like tabular
data and you basically have you can make
like snapshots of this but here we're
talking about
images and labels and annotations and
how do we build on top of this um in the
old version did this is how we started
out we had segmentation we had like a
folder of images and then we had Json
files with like all these labels but
then when you add an asset you have to
go back to your original images and then
you also have to annotate this part um
these assets and it became like a big
Jungle of like files laying around and
folders with images same for
classification we um set per asset per
damage category we make like folders
with good quality bad
quality um but this requires to save
your images multiple times and it's not
the best solution so we transitioned
into something more scalable and that is
to put these labels in a
database um so what we did was create a
database with a label per asset type and
per damage category um this requires us
to save the image once and just refer to
it according to like a certain file name
and we created an append only
functionality that means that we can
create more labels for the same image if
the label actually changes if we made a
mistake in the training set and we see
that after we do our validation and we
can retroactively add another label and
use the latest one and that's how we
enable data versioning by querying this
database and say Hey I want the data set
as it it looked on this specific date
that means it looks a bit like this
let's say we start out with this small
data set we have um images a b c and d
two of them are bad and we added them on
the 1st of September then a week later
we add two more images on the 8th of
December um then we add another label
because we found out that image B was
actually good quality and not bad
quality we see that we added this on the
12th of September um and if we now quy
the database to make uh to start a new
training pipeline we can actually like
omit this line from the database and
keep the other ones um and if we would
want to go back to see hey how did our
model actually trained before this we
can create this table from a previous
date and we still have the exact same
labels without saving any information
twice um all right second uh uh third
part that we want to highlight during
the mlops versus computer vision is how
do you do validation and integration
testing when we're talking about models
that work with images and basically what
we did was we annotated a full video
with all the segmentation mask
classification uh properties the track
objects to be able to make performance
metrics over um over a a pipeline run so
it's kind of like the last step in our
cacd uh pipeline it runs in arodo um the
idea is to fully annotate something and
whenever we make a chain change in our
model or somewhere in the pipeline we
can run this again and get like um these
performance metrics like for
segmentation we can take the IOU for
localization like the mean absolute
error Precision recall for each
individual object to guarantee that you
have like a model that works well in
production
all right um then let's proceed to the
last part of the presentation uh the
lessons learned that we had from this
project typically we learn as humans
from mistakes and we also take this
concept of having our machine learning
model learn from the mistakes um because
ml models create a lot of false positive
and negatives and it's hard to adjust
the actual model um to account for these
specific things they're rather complex
models we use trans for learning to to
train them and then we were rethinking
this as a data problem because we simply
did not give the model enough data
enough opportunity to learn this
specific example so what we did is
adding all false positives and negatives
to the training set such that in the
next iteration when we train the model
it's at least able to learn these
mistakes that it did the previous time
um and here we can also use a feature
from the dashboard because the end users
are actually able to um correct mistakes
that the model did and these mistakes
can then be feedback to the training
pipeline uh to make sure we have a
continuous learning
setup um what we also found was that
there is quite some disagreement between
how we annotate the labels the
perspective of a stakeholder was okay
now that we're doing inspections with
the computer means we should be more
objective and more consistent with how
we classify our our assets right well um
the inspectors disagreed on up to 50% of
the annotations in a setting of like a
multivariate classification model which
means like the data set is not even like
unified in this decision so if we train
a model on this of course it's not going
to be objective and consistent so this
gave like a false sense of confidence in
the model performance and we actually
had to make the problem simpler to make
sure that at least the inspector the
humans agree on what they're doing
before we start teaching a model how to
do this how to automate this um so my
takeaway here was to always build the
simplest version first first and then
iterate over it in instead of trying to
make the complex
version lastly there is this thing of
detecting things that are not there this
is one of the questions that we got
along the way um hey can you detect
things that are not there let's say
there's supposed to be a lamp post here
but it's missing this is kind of a
non-computer vision problem because you
cannot detect what is not there um but
still there's a there's a way how to
deal with this because if we drive past
these this street past this invisible
lamp post every time and consistently we
fail to recognize it if we have enough
passes in this same street then we can
actually make the case like hey we don't
recognize anything but the data say says
there should be something something um
so maybe we can actually find things
that are
missing um okay then to summarize I
think these are the most important
things that I learned on the
intersection of mlops and computer
vision which is build Standalone
components that you can swap out and
improve over organize the training data
in such a way that you actually built on
top of it instead of creating this huge
Jungle of annotation files and folders
with images in certain
categories um always build the simplest
version First this is kind of the scrum
philosophy I think we all know it in
theory but when it's in practice it's
still hard to do because you always have
these IDs that you want to do start
simple just build that first and then
iterate um learn from the mistakes do
that as human but also do that as
machine learning model so build this
feedback loop if you have the
opportunity to do so feedback the
mistakes into your training pipeline
such that you don't make those mistakes
again and then lastly think about how
you want to validate and integrate uh do
integration testing for your models um
because that's the only way how you can
build confidence in your model outside
of your training Pipeline and inside of
like the production
setting then I want to show my gratitude
to all the open source components that
we use in this project this project is
fully built on open source these are the
ones um that we used and we would not
have been able to achieve this without
these components so thanks um thanks for
that and that uh concludes my
[Applause]
talk